>> Jesse: CELEBRATING 11 YEARS
OF "THE FIVE" AGAIN, BECAUSE
SOMEONE WAS NOT HERE YESTERDAY
AND HE IS MAD HE WAS LEFT OUT,
SO WE ARE DOING IT EVEN BIGGER
AND BETTER FOR GREG.
GREG, WE HAVE PROPS FOR YOU.
AND CAKE.
>> Judge Jeanine: NOT MORE
CAKE, OH, MY GOD.
>> Greg: WOW, WHAT IS THAT?
THOSE ARE AMAZING.
>> Jesse: CAN WE PUT THIS UP
SO EVERYBODY CAN SEE?
LOOK AT THAT CAKE RIGHT THERE!
BEFORE YOU KNOW, HE SLICES THEM
UPCOMING A SLICE THESE UP, I
HAVE NEVER BEFORE?
I HAVE TO DO A SHOW IN
10 MINUTES.
THIS IS HOW YOU CELEBRATE.
>> Judge Jeanine: I HAVE EATEN
SO MUCH ON THE SHOW.
WHAT DID YOU SAY?
>> Jesse: NOTHING.
IT WOULD NOT BE THE SAME WITHOUT
THE MAN, THE MYTH, THE UNICORN
LOVING LEDGE AND WE ALL IS
GREG GUTFELD.
HUMBLE BEGINNINGS AS THOSE SHOWS
COFFEE BOY AND FITNESS TRAINER,
TOTAL DOMINANCE AS THE KING OF
LATE-NIGHT SLAYING ALL THE
LIBERAL LATE-NIGHT COMPETITION.
ARE YOU GETTING ENOUGH ATTENTION
NOW?
>> Greg: YES.
>> Dana: AND THE BALLOONS.
>> Jesse: YOU CAN'T INHALE
THEM.
>> Greg: IT'S AMAZING.
>> Harold: DO WE HAVE ANY MORE
FOOTAGE OF THE PEOPLE WHO SET
ALL OF THE NICE THINGS
YESTERDAY?
>> Judge Jeanine: WAS THERE
ANY FOOTAGE OF PEOPLE WHO SAID
NICE THINGS?
>> Greg: THIS IS FOR ME, I GET
TO SAY SOMETHING.
WE SHOULD THINK ALL THE FANS.
THE SHOW IS AMAZING.
EVERY YEAR IT JUST KEEPS GETTING
BETTER AND BETTER AND BETTER.
LARGER AND LARGER AND IT'S
AMAZING, PEOPLE THAT HATE OUR
SIDE OF POLITICS STILL LOVE THE
SHOW.
BECAUSE WE ARE REAL PEOPLE AND
WE TALK ABOUT REAL STUFF AND WE
ACT LIKE REAL PEOPLE.
>> Dana: WE ARE REALLY FUNNY.
>> Judge Jeanine: AND YOU ARE
FUNNY.
>> Jesse: ARE YOU FINISHED,
YOU UNICORN LOVER?
>> Dana: ANIMALS ARE GREAT.
>> Jesse: WE HAVE SOME MORE IN
STORE.
DID YOU FIND SOMETHING?
>> Greg: ♪♪ I'M
GREG GUTFELD ♪♪
>> Judge Jeanine: IT'S 5:00 IN
NEW YORK CITY IN THAT HAND IS
GREG.
>> Greg: CAN WE CONTEMPLATE
HIM LIKE WE WOULD A PAINTING BY
VERMEER.
IT'S LIKE I HAVE A MEDICAL
DISORDER.
THIS BOOK IS DOING GREAT, BY THE
WAY.
PURCHASE MY BOOK.
IT'S THE MONOLOGUES.
I HAVE ONE FOR EVERYONE OF YOU.
AND I FORGOT TO SIGN THEM.
I'VE BEEN CARRYING THE SHOW
FOREVER.
JESSE AND I ARE NO LONGER
FRIENDS.
WE ARE NO LONGER FRIENDS, AND
IT'S NOT EVEN A HUMAN BEING.
THE THING IS THEY WANTED TO DO
AN EARLY MORNING SHOOT, I'M NOT
GETTING UP FOR ANYTHING.
THERE IS ONLY ONE PERSON.
>> Judge Jeanine: CAROL.
>> Greg: AT LEAST I KNOW THAT
SOME PEOPLE DON'T WATCH ME.
SPEAKING OF PROGRESS, I PASSED
MY DRIVERS TEST.
BECAUSE I AM ALONE IN THE
STUDIO, HE NEEDED SOMEBODY TO
KEEP ME COMPANY.
AND WHO BETTER THAN MY LITTLE
FRIEND I LOVE YOU, AMERICA.
"ONE MORE THING" IS UP NEXT.
♪♪ ANIMALS ARE GREAT ♪♪
I JUST WANTED TO HAVE A KIDS
PROGRAM LIKE YOU, JESSE.
>> Judge Jeanine: WE SEE IT
NOW.
>> Greg: AND YOU SEE IT.
>> Jesse: DID YOU JUST BURP?
>> Greg: ♪♪ I'VE GOT TO PEE ♪
♪ I'VE GOT TO PEE ♪♪
>> Jesse: YOU ARE ON ERROR.
>> Greg: I DID NOT KNOW THAT I
WAS ON ERROR.
I SAY IT ALL THE TIME AND I WAS
LIKE, I DID NOT EVEN KNOW.
I WAS SITTING THERE AND I TURNED
OFF THE THING AND THAT REMOTE
THING AND I WAS NOT PAYING ANY
ATTENTION.
>> Jesse: SHOULD I THROW THIS
CAKE AT GREG GUTFELD'S FACE.
>> Greg: MY GOD.
>> Jesse: I AM HAPPY THAT YOU
ARE HAPPY AND WE ARE HAPPY FOR
YOU.
>> Judge Jeanine